greg how you doing i love collider
oh thanks man we love you too how you
doing doing great doing great
i'm actually going to be on the uh the
witching hour i think uh
with leary and haley yes oh we look we
look forward to it i'll let him know you
said hello
yeah um so
as a horror director one thing i love
about this film is how
important love is and they're very like
real
emotional relationship and partnership
with each other
as a horror director how do you approach
these kind of more earnest
expressions of love and romance was
there any like kind of learning curve or
anything like that
um great question
i think that the learning curve
i don't have need the learning curve
because i have such a wonderful wife who
is you know every day you know if we're
going to talk about that i would say
that you know she's honestly you know my
rock and uh you know uh i i think that
i think one of the reasons that i'm such
a fan of the the conjuring
universe i'm coming out this movie as a
first is
it's because i love the warrens and i
love their relationship i you know i
grew up on
horror movies and so i'm always
attracted to that
i think that the reason that i keep on
coming back to this franchise and i
think other people keep on coming back
to it
is because of the warrens and their
relationship and their love story
as as unexpected as it is and it is
funny because it is so earnest it is
so true and i think that that's in a way
it's disarming it's it was disarming to
me in this that first
movie how how much
their love and their faith drove them
yeah i grew up catholic but i'm also
very much a skeptic and so
i think that and i'm also so in so many
ways a cynic and it's
i i love
i've loved watched watching their their
relationship grow
yeah um definitely not the intro that
you're thinking about with a a horror
movie guys this is ridiculously scary i
should probably
emphasize that for collider fans out
there
let's get into the scares then i'm
curious and i think a lot of our readers
will be too
from a process standpoint when you take
a script
and start crafting your set pieces and
your scares
how much of that is kind of like
invented by you
how much of that is kind of baked into
the script what is it like taking
a set piece or a scare from script to
screen
as extraordinary as a lot of the stuff
is in the movie
it starts with the real story you know
the waterbed
sequence is something that a lot of
people have talked about that started
with
the real story the david's possession
before the story even gets to arne
a lot of david's behavior his possession
can be traced back to this incident
in when they moved into this house and
there was this
this bed it i it wasn't a water bed but
it was this mattress that had this burnt
stain
that was mirrored on the very bottom of
it on the floor
and they just sent david ran into that
room
he had some kind of encounter that no
one really knows what happened
and ever since then he had been changed
he
some people say he was possessed some
people say with something else
but um all of these scenes are based on
the real story and we build off of that
i think that
for the for instance with that with that
story with the
with the bed we evolved it into being a
water bed there was definitely some
nightmare on elm street
inspiration within that and
you know you think about how to how to
make these scenes
visual how to build tension how to how
to create
that that scary movie arc within the
within the scene but but again i think
the power of it honestly the exorcism is
a scene that really
affects people yeah and we play that
real recording
the real recording of the exorcism of
this young boy we play it at the end of
the movie
and i think it's just a good reminder
and it was a good reminder as we were
making it that
believer or skeptic whatever happened
there was something very real that
happened to these people
and it was definitely emotionally real
and being able to just go back to that i
think that that was one of those things
that just
it anchored the the movie and these
scenes in reality
yeah absolutely um my final question for
you
as a director stepping into a franchise
helmed by someone with such a strong
voice like james wan
how do you kind of walk the line of like
asserting or flexing yourself as a
director but still kind of
maybe paying homage to what he did with
the first two conjurings
i'm coming at it as a fan and i
you know the last thing i would want to
hear as a fan is we took it in a totally
different direction
and we just abandoned everything that
was set up before i wouldn't like that
and i i want to honor this world and
these characters
and i want to continue their story at
the same time
this is a very different case this is a
very different experience for the
warrens it's
it's it was from the very beginning it
was going to be a different film
whatever i did to it so i was always
just trying to
i tried to put ego
and that that flexing of style and all
of that i
put that into like the back burner
because that wasn't important for me it
was important to
to honor this world to tell the story of
the warrens
and and really fill this movie with
surprises
i think that being a fan you want that
same experience
that first awesome scary experience that
you had with the first
conjuring movie but you also want
something different you know that's the
thing it's it's always that push pull
because if you get
exactly what you got in the beginning if
we just did the clap game again
no one would be happy it's like they
want something
different we all want something
different and we want those surprises
so i think that's what this movie has
and i'm excited for fans to see it
absolutely thanks so much for your time
that was really great yeah thank you it
was uh it was great to talk to you
yeah we'll see you at the witching hour
thanks michael